Hello Freak bitches.
The stars have aligned.
The prophecy has come true.
Alex Jones and Eddie Bravo
together on episode nine one one.
So imagine thousands of emails
come out with them talking about,
we'll have the kids ready.
Six,
seven and eight in the hot tub
at this time and there'd be,
I don't see anything like that.
Oh,
it gets you.
It gets really great.
Where did it say that it was Jim's emails?
There's fricking thousands of them,
but it said,
we'll get the kids in the hot tub.
I never saw that.
Can you,
can you see if you could find that Jamie?
That seems like we are.
You have to be real careful in how you
describe these things in high talk about
these things because people were looking
for any little tiny thing to discredit
it.
Say,
I always wondered how
they're getting away with it.
It's so out in the open.
How come there isn't more of a psychic
vampires stealing the energy from the
kids?
Megan Kelly,
so pretty.
She can say whatever the fuck she wants.
She looks like an old trainee.
I love her.
Do you think she looks like an old tranny?
You're hilarious.
No,
I don't like old trainings,
but I think she's hot.
You don't like,
you don't think Meghan
Kelly's not just one.
I insulted her.
She's a globalist.
So then site start accusing
me of covering up the,
the Podesta stuff before.
It's called pizza gate and then I get
blamed for being behind pizza gate and I'm
not even bitching.
I'm explaining what it's like to really
be trying to get at the truth and the
people take the fact that it's complex.
She'd be better at this to me jokes,
you know how to put stuff out,
clear and parse it.
I just know all this crap.
When you get crazy,
you still rent.
People won't listen to me
because I've got too much data.
You imagine what this is like.
I mean it's just,
I'm sick of it.
I don't know everything that's going on,
but I know this,
I have good CIA people and
FBI and secret service.
Okay.
Telling me.
Yes Alex.
It's worse than,
you know,
keep getting him.
It's going to come out and it's
starting to come out and say,
watch.
When we started arresting
the pedophile networks,
we're going to roll up the Democrats
and the Republicans that are involved.
And that's why Trump
said any speeches at the,
at the inaugural.
This is not about parties.
We're taking these people on.
We're bringing God back in.
Even somebody that wasn't very religious
like Trump has gotten religion learning
about this because let
me tell you something,
Trump's not a devil worshiper and he loves
God and he's been briefed on all this
and he's going to roll their ass up
so the pedophiles better get ready.
I foxes totally get anyone no matter what.
Fuck yeah,
dude.
Come on.
Get one for Eddie Bravo two I did.
Oh was just tobacco.
Yes.
Very.
It's strong tobacco from Mexico.
I guess.
I am in California.
This was for medical reason.
100% medical reasons and legal.
Okay.
Buzz Aldrin.
I do no buzz Aldrin.
Buzz Aldrin said,
I want to come on your show and I and I,
I'm not gonna get into all the heat.
I know he lives here in La
and one time I ran into him,
but let's leave it at that.
And he said,
I want to come on your show.
And I said,
all right,
well come on.
And it's the only interview
he said and he goes,
I'm going to tell you Alex
and your audience alone.
He said,
there is an obelisk just like
2001 it's on the moon of Mars,
the moon,
and it's sending a transmission and it's
all real and it's all Egypt and there's
aliens and everything else.
The word is they got military
bases on the other side.
Alex was in the fifties what
do you think we got now?
So you think they have no,
wait a minute.
They have bases on the moon.
Well,
I'll never get into all this stuff,
right,
don't do that.
But let's just say it's super advanced.
They sent a bunch of people to
their company and threatened them.
The next week after I heard
him and he laid it out,
he said in 1967 we certified
at the Stanford Research
Institute that he was able
to control hurricanes,
Korea,
hurricanes,
and steer hurricanes,
all that got black budgeted shutdown.
And then they got into these arrays
where they could use antennas.
And out of that,
and Westinghouse came,
came the,
uh,
the,
the whole heart program.
So in the 60s,
they could create control
and steer or kill hurricanes.
That's why you Google now bill and
Melinda Gates bought all those patents and
the quote,
Bill Gates is going to save
the world from bad weather.
Bill Gates wants to stop hurricanes.
Google.
Hell,
in 2005,
the Department of Energy Program for
Aerosol testing was $5 billion a year.
So under us code title 50,
Chapter 32 subsection 1,528,
paragraph B,
is that true?
You nailed that,
right?
Yes.
We need from Mars under US code.
Do you live on that obelisk?
That was fucking insane.
Let me just tell you,
I need to remember the time and last
time the Cheetah fuck this mother fucker
listed under us.
Code title finish number
32 1,528 paragraph B.
That's insane.
Under that,
say it's slow that Jamie write it up,
but the big secret is once you have
a crystal ball and know the future,
you can add stimuli beforehand and
make decisions that control the future.
And so then it's the end of consciousness
and freewill for individuals as we
know.
And a true 2.0 and a very bad way.
Hive mind consciousness with an AI jacked
into everyone knowing our hopes and
dreams,
delivering it to us,
not in some PKD wire-heads system where
we plug in and give up on consciousness
because of unlimited pleasure,
but because we were already wired
in and absorbed before we knew it.
By giving over our
consciousness to the system,
our daily decisions that it was able
to manipulate and control into a larger
system.
There's now a human counterstrike taking
place to shut this off before it gets
fully into place and to
block these systems and to
try to have an actual debate
about where humanity goes and cut off
the pedophiles and psychic vampires that
are control of this AI system before
humanities destroy humanity is only
controlled of Ai.
How would they get,
how'd the pedophiles
getting controlling the pet,
the pedophiles it at whatever level,
the devil,
whatever you want to call it,
this inner dimensional thing that gives
them advanced Offworld technology.
The fallen one that's not of this world
is giving them advanced knowledge.
Top systems have been used
before on other populations.
What that Satan,
but what do you,
what are you talking about?
That's what it does was his rant.
I'm not sure we're going
to go back to that.
He's definitely high as fuck.
This is the stuff about buzz Aldrin is
telling him some fucking exactly crazy
shit and I'm like,
Oh my God,
I'm too fucked up.
You fucked up.
I told you we are going
to get them all dried.
We had to get her mind and there is a
full out war inside the government of guys
that like to eat steaks and drink beer
and having women versus a bunch of
Potbelly pedophiles.
Whoa.
I don't claim to have all the answers and
I'm not here to boost your Trump cause
I'm tied to his wagon.
If I attack Trump,
I'd make more money.
This isn't about money.
It's about the truth.
Trump really is trying to cut taxes
and make people successful and wealthy.
He really does care
about the average person,
the elite of set up a
plan to enslave people,
to make folks poor and all I'm asking you
to do is get past thinking that you're
part of the establishment or you're
smart because you're anti-Trump.
I'm asking you to actually look at what's
really been going on and understand
that Democrats,
Republicans come and go.
Some are good,
some are bad.
The whole power structure has been
against Trump for a very serious reason.
Trump is coming after them and really
is attempting to bring down this whole
global system and that's when
all hell is breaking loose.
So I just want your viewers and listeners
know I'm not some political hack.
Like you said earlier,
I used to be against Bush.
I wish Obama would have been real.
The point is they got to,
Obama would Trump,
he doesn't give a damn.
They admit they're offering and money,
everything.
He doesn't listen.
He's like,
is he in the middle of an awakening?
Yes,
because he could easily have been a
billionaire to me two years ago who?
Who bought all the mainstream shit,
but he was,
it's like they're interdimensionally
connected like why is it always blew?
You're a loser,
slap you in the face of
the back of the head.
It's like,
how are they so good at?
And it's not movie deal.
That was the greatest
thing you've ever said.
No,
I'm serious.
You just invited a door for people going
who you're a loser and then try to slap
you in the back of the head.
It's going to happen now.
Started turning our brain is able
to tune into the lowest dimension,
the highest dimension.
Humans are basically really powerful
creatures that can live right close to
sons.
They're highly radioactive,
nothing else can live.
It's close with very short
lives because we're like,
hey hive organism that actually lives
second to second in the space time
continuum.
It's like a hundred years,
it's a second.
And we transmit our data up to be able
to live next to likely the stargate jump
gates that are,
that are sons.
So because we live so close to the sons,
we only have like
milliseconds to be alive.
So we're actually a hive organism that
keeps transmitting up to the next species
in our,
in a hierarchical system,
and then down below us.
So we're alive right now in this continuum
and we're trying to progress and,
and,
and make things better.
And the elites are trying to make sure
that we don't dial into that incredible
knowledge we've got as a species.
It basically die as a species so that
we're not competitors on the next level as
the Bible says of their dimensional plane.
But yeah,
but you don't believe that.
You're just saying
that's what they believe.
Oh yes,
exactly.
I'm not going to believe in anything.
What do you believe?
No,
I mean,
I believe in research present to you.
We will try to do more to speed the
deportation of illegal aliens who were
arrested for crimes to better identify
illegal aliens in the work face as
recommended by the commission headed
by former congresswoman Barbara Jordan.
We are a nation immigrants,
but we are also a nation of laws.
It is wrong and ultimately self defeat.
Shut the fuck up about it will power.
That's not,
no.
Okay.
Let's uh,
that's about it folks.
Are you kidding?
Everybody take one day.
If I give you full power,
you're going to be in the photo pit
where I think we've hit it's five.
We're going to wrap this up.
We got it.
We did a good job.
We put together and ask one more question.
Go ahead.
One more.
And a super nice guy.
He seems like a nice guy.
He worked there like in college right now.
Beyond that,
beyond that,
he admitted it.
He's part of the like wimps.
CIA.
Real wait a minute.
CIA has a web division a
if you're the aster family.
Lucky is,
yeah.
Or the Vanderbilt,
Vanderbilt.
John Jayco.
Mr. Meyer Smith,
his name is Maya name too.
If you
guys can't talk over each other,
that's what it comes down to.
Hardly talking.
I know,
but he's talking about this.
You talk when you're talking
about a Greenland shark
in the show.
Yes.
Eddie Bravo back.
No,
no,
no.
I'm gonna fuck you up on my left side.
And my left hand is my
strongest cause I'm a south.
Everybody.
Oh,
you guys are beautiful.
Thanks for listening.
And thanks for tuning in to
episode nine one one Bravo.
Alex Jones and Joe Rogan signing off.
Okay.